[Music]
you're happy now you met the guy and
you're happy
i converted to judaism you converted to
judaism
is that true were you raised in what
faith were you raised
being catholic yeah you too yeah did you
go
did you go to catholic school i went to
catholic catholic
i went to a regular uh public school and
then uh at night on
one day a week i had to go to a big
castle where there were nuns
and uh with the night i don't remember
anything they had the big they had the
big like wimple they had the giant you
know the wings on their heads
they're mean i'm not gonna say that i'm
not gonna say they were mean those nuns
were fine to me
okay well maybe they hate women because
nuns were so mean to me they would slap
me
they would like grab my chin and of
course the priests are like so nice to
the boys
yeah and it's very hard for like a young
woman to get any attention
yeah you can imagine
tough uh tough going there so you
converted now
now you are you are jewish now yeah
i mean well what do you mean yeah that
doesn't sound like a real like hardcore
conversion well i took like
19 corset 19 four-hour courses
right to convert to judaism okay it's
very interesting there was like
there was two types of people in the
judaism class there would be
um you know actual genuine seekers who
really wanted to learn something
and then they would be like young
beautiful women being forced to convert
by their old fiancees with turkey necks
old fiance with the turkey necks a lot
of turkey nuts okay
all right and which which one are you um
i don't really feel comfortable
answering that question um but i
did bring a picture of my fiance okay
let's take a look you see there he is
that's not him
no i really do i can see why you were
reluctant to get married
you're a seeker then you're a seeker
you're a seeker no
judaism is a beautiful religion yeah
it's uh
you get to have a weekly shabbat it's uh
which is just like a party
every friday uh these courses did not
stick with you
i think you just listened to one podcast
and you were like i'm jewish now i got
this down
you're part of this beautiful religion
thieves in culture
abortions are cool
[Laughter]
no no no one's going around staying up
no they do
i mean you could get an abortion on
every jewish holiday and it would be
okay
what i mean i'm not saying i'm going to
get an abortion but you know it's just
nice to it's like triple a like you're
not going to use all those toes but
no it's just nice to know
do you have a big catholic following i
just i just
i just was given a signal that jews
don't want you anymore
get her out get her out of here she's
out send it back to those heathen
catholics
they they just think differently about
it i think differently like
the cat like catholicism they believe
that even if you are raped you should
not get an abortion
right hardcore this is my comedy act
that's yeah
yeah this is your comedy act this is
fantastic
no so i don't i don't want to think it's
fair to say that every catholic believes
that
you know no but i did go to the vatican
and because i was converting i was like
well i should maybe check in
yeah so i happen to be in rome and
i went to confession and i told him and
i was like
you know i'm hi and he's like have you
ever have you ever made abortion that's
what he said because he was
because he had a you know he was roman
yeah all right italian
italian he was a roman centurion
have you ever make abortions that's
natasha
[Laughter]
so then i told him i was converting to
judaism he's like well what can you do
like that's how bad it is over there
even they don't you know he's like hey
you can convert to another religion but
yeah
still be a part of our thing maybe he it
sounds like he converted a week ago
he told me he goes can you just come
once a year
to church yeah yeah and i said i think i
can do that
all right and then uh yeah he's he was
cool with it he was cool with that
here i don't think i think you are going
to be i don't know what religion you're
going to be
in a year but it will not be either
jewish or catholic
is my prediction i think you are bopping
all over the place i
there's no judgment here
you